oh odyssey
if you haven't seen it get on iplayer
because there is some crying that starts
just then that goes on for
like 20 minutes
i mean
it's unbelievable
i mean i wasn't there that day it must
have been so stressed yeah i haven't
seen this episode i remember being there
just yeah
and uh i i remember the crying i know
that it was really really tragic it was
really challenging but this is like this
is the olympics of drag so you know the
girls are uh you know they've got their
hopes up real high and and on this
series you know the girls eliminate one
another you know as opposed to the other
series where
oh i do it
yeah it feels it feels so much more like
there are sort of dirty tactics going
like removing competition that's not the
worst just the one that might win it
that's exactly how it works that's why
it's so uh gut-wrenching you know
they've made it this far only to be you
know
slashed by one of their sisters
[Laughter]
you're rooting for blue aren't you well
well then i watched these days episodes
no i mean
no if you turned hard because i you know
i think panchayat is amazing so
it is hard but i guess it is the
competition isn't it it's just the way
the cookie crumbles sometimes yeah it's
just like hollywood exactly imagine the
oscars were like that
in some ways they are that'd be great of
all the nominees and a lipstick oh my
gosh wow
[Music]
you